make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with
batman ghost stories and we get the
origin of
ghost maker now i say this origin
loosely not because we don't get a full
origin
we do but i feel like this might be
expanded on later on by james tennion so
kind of keep your eyes out for the idea
that we might get more of an expansion
here
um another thing that we're doing here
is i'm going to give away a rob core
ring on the discord server so make sure
you guys check out the discord server
down in the description
um i'm going to give one away on friday
at 6 p.m eastern time when i do my
weekly q a
uh so make sure you guys check that out
uh and then i'm also gonna list rob core
rings for sale again
uh once we get around to uh really close
to christmas time right so maybe here in
about a week or so
uh i'm gonna list them for sale that way
you guys can buy them and then you guys
can get them in time for christmas so
that's gonna be cool that's gonna be fun
uh i also will have size 12 rings so
those of you guys who need size 12s we
actually have those in stock now uh they
just recently came in
so yes uh so having said that um we are
we're covering this origin
right now this whole thing comes in the
aftermath of the last video the last
story that we did
where batman alongside clown killer and
harley quinn
were all basically captured by ghost
maker right they were all defeated by
ghost maker so at this point they're all
basically stuck in arkham asylum and
it's one of these funny things where
batman basically wakes up before
everybody else but that's because
of the fact that he's batman that's not
true it's because of the fact that ghost
maker
uh didn't give him as much of a i didn't
give him as strong of a shot of the uh
of the basically the thing that knocked
him out the anesthetic as he did with
harley quinn and clown killer right
because he wanted a batman to wake up
early because he wanted to have this
conversation directly with him and the
whole idea is we don't really find out
the full depth of this conversation
instead
it's really him just kind of talking to
batman and saying that with everything
going on that this this clown killer kid
is basically just or at least clown
hunter i guess his official name
uh is basically just the latest symptom
of this disease right that batman has
essentially failed as a superhero in
almost every way
right that gotham is not better because
of batman gotham's actually worse
and so what we end up doing here before
we get this kind of full-on explanation
is we switch over to barbara gordon
right we switch over to batgirl uh who's
basically talking to dick grayson right
while you know
a crime is kind of happening some
criminals are robbing a bank and dick
grayson's beating them up and talking to
her at the same time which makes sense
right because you know dick grayson he
can do almost anything
and so what we end up finding out is
that in the time with batman having been
missing
for the last six hours and the time that
ghost maker's been in the city of gotham
uh that professor pig was found back in
arkham asylum despite the fact that he
was on
he was on the loose the the yakuza
triads and the whisper gang have all
just abandoned the city completely
right that six people were found dead at
the iceberg lounge of the penguin and
the penguin himself
is believed to be underground in one of
his bunkers that effectively the
criminal element in gotham has just
vanished right just seemingly
disappeared
overnight these guys just took off and
that's when nightwing kind of chimes in
i can't believe the ghost maker actually
came to gotham and it basically gives us
this idea that dick grayson knows who
the ghost maker is and is something that
he's actually known for quite some time
because that's what barbara gordon asked
him she's like how do you know who the
ghost maker is and he's like oh i've
known about him for a long time right
but i've only ever seen him once and
what he does is he recalls this story
from back when he was younger right back
when he around the time that he first
became robin
and he talks about how him and batman
had basically been chasing some guy
right you know
some low level guy that was making a
break and fleeing the united states and
batman and them had basically tracked
him down to this location and once they
got to an
airport where this guy was going to be
taking off at then suddenly they were
met by the arrival of uh of ghost maker
who had already essentially captured
this villain and as soon as they get out
and as soon as batman sees its ghost
maker batman gets back in the batwing
and then tells robin we're going back to
gotham and when robin's like
why like like who is this guy like why
are we just going to go back to go back
to gotham batman kind of starts talking
about when he was younger and when he
started undergoing this whole this whole
process
of becoming batman right yeah if you
guys any of you guys recall uh this is
especially important during batman year
one by frank miller which really covered
all that stuff it's one of the reasons
why
uh frank miller's batman work is kind of
considered to be some of the seminal
batman work that exists out there
because it did so much retelling of his
origin and a lot of those things that
have kind of been changed or removed
over the years are in a lot of ways
ignored by fans and it's kind of
considered to be like the definitive
story why batman year one is largely
believed to be the definitive batman
story batman year zero from the new 52 a
lot of fans kind of uh
basically marry that with batman year
one and then just kind of combine them
together for a singular story right and
say this is how bruce wayne became
batman this is how it all sort of
sort of came together but the long and
short of this is that when bruce wayne
starts talking about his life when he
was younger that he traveled around the
world to all these different places
right that when his parents died
he made a promise to himself made this
oath that he would basically
live a war against criminals and he
wanted to become the kind of person that
could fulfill that oath and so he went
from place to place
training with all different kinds of
people right he trained with zatanna's
father he trained with wildcat i think
is what a name his name is i don't know
he trained with all these different
people but along the way
he met this young guy and this young guy
that he met really kind of proved to be
somebody whose ego was just ridiculously
unbearable
but it was a person who thought very
much the same way bruce wayne did that
it wasn't just
enough to become skilled in like a
singular martial art and dedicate their
life to that he wanted to become the
absolute
best crime fighter he could possibly be
and what bruce wayne found here was a
kind of camaraderie right it was him and
this guy
working together and kind of presenting
each other with these almost unsolvable
mysteries these unsolvable problems
basically how to make the world a better
place dreaming about technology in the
future
how crime can be solved different things
like that and so when with bruce wayne
kind of finding this friend
this guy who was basically as
egotistical as he was
was a very very strong competitor and
was a very close friend of bruce wayne
bruce wayne finally revealed his story
saying that he's the son of thomas and
martha that his parents were killed and
that following that he basically wanted
to kind of wage war against crime
in order to bring all that to an end
right so nobody would have to go through
what he went through the response to
that was
ghost maker got pissed he got so mad and
the reason why he tried to kill bruce
wayne is that he told him he was weak
that ghost maker was angry because he
believed that he'd found somebody
like him right somebody who was doing
all of this for the art of it
right because it was just a thing that
they desire the thing that they pursued
to simply just
better themselves and better the world
around them that it wasn't some childish
idea of vengeance now this is a really
interesting concept this is a really
interesting thing a lot of times when
you see characters like ghost maker
presented in comic books
that have an origin story like this
where they meet the main hero and the
two of them become enemies
sometimes it's because of the fact that
especially in a situation like this that
they were somehow
less capable than the hero themselves
and it's all just been an effort to
prove that they're just as capable for
ghost maker it's not that way
it's like no i really want to make the
world a better place i want to do this
to make the world better
you're doing it because you're mad that
your mommy and daddy got shot and it's
just and that's basically what it is
right and that's what's so cool is
because it moves ghost maker away from
this guy who's just like once upon a
time
him and bruce wayne met each other bruce
wayne got a black belt before him and
he's been pissed ever since
instead of that instead of something
stupid and basic like that it's no like
you're just filled with vengeance right
like you don't really have a desire
to make the world better because you're
being altruistic you want to make the
world better because your mommy and
daddy got shot you're full of rage and
you want to make sure that nobody else
has to go through that again
golly gee you're going to save the day
and in a lot of ways
it kind of diminishes batman if i'm
being honest with you guys
i feel like it kind of diminishes him
not necessarily in a terrible way
it doesn't make him any less capable but
it really puts into perspective
the goal of batman right he's just a
little kid crying because his parents
got shot that it really is
all just based on vengeance and anger
he's in essence every ounce of a
vigilante whereas
ghost maker is being presented here from
the words of batman
as a guy who's doing all this because he
genuinely and truly
wants to make the world better and that
totally changes the idea that he'll just
kill villains right it's not him killing
them because it's easy
it is i mean technically it is easy so
by default that's a true statement
but he does that because dead men cannot
be repeat offenders
dead man cannot go back and commit
crimes all over again now i know it
seems to take away from the human
element but ghost maker also seems to
kind of have this this sort of threshold
right
where it's one thing to run criminals
out of town it's another to kill them
and there's this kind of standard that
he arbitrarily creates which is
once they start committing acts
egregious enough then we kill them and
it seems to be the standard he created
which is a reasonable one
is that if a villain basically becomes a
killer then we kill him
in turn right they they sacrificed their
right to life when they took somebody
else's and so
it's kind of interesting here right it's
it's an interesting concept because from
there like
robin kind of looks at that and he's
listening to the story that batman's
telling him and he's like well you know
you're not weak right i mean like i
don't have to tell you that but you know
that's not true
and batman's like well i don't feel weak
and that's when when dick grayson picks
up on it but you miss your friend and
batman's like
yes i miss my friend i miss the person
that i spent so much time with now
following that and when he continues
kind of talking to barbara gordon about
all this
one of the things that he says is that
when batman jump started batman
incorporated he reached out to uh to
ghost maker now for those of you guys
who don't know what that is
batman incorporated was part of the
grant morrison run right so
grant morrison's batman run is
considered by a lot of fans to be
one of the absolute best man best batman
runs and rightfully so it's amazing like
it's a ridiculously good batman
series of batman stories but the idea of
the chronology is that during the events
of final crisis
batman was shot by doomsday with you
know his omega sanction or whatever and
technically it should have killed batman
because it would have killed anybody
else who was just a regular human but he
was set back in time because he's too
popular for dc to cancel and so that
gave us the story the return of bruce
wayne
during that time when bruce wayne was
traveling through time that you had dick
grayson who became batman
and damian wayne became the new robin
and so you got that series of stories
you know focusing on the dick grayson
batman era and then of course once bruce
wayne came back
his thought was okay we need to expand
the bat family right and so that's when
the bat family went international and so
it was basically him
traveling around to all these different
places where he found individuals who
were
effectively people fighting crime that
seemed to have like minds right so
that's where you end up getting like
lucious fox's son
you know where you get you have like
what the batwing i think is what he's
called you have like a lot of those
characters that kind of come into play
bruce wayne grabbed a lot of these guys
and then brought them into the bat
family
basically to kind of make batman a
worldwide concept uh when he reached out
to ghost maker it apparently didn't go
well right now this is james tanian
throwing in new information that didn't
exist before right because ghost maker
didn't exist until this story so he's
just kind of adding this stuff
in uh and then it turned into when dick
grayson was working for spiral as you
know during that
terrible run where he was a spy that he
basically ended up looking around for
ghost maker and that most of the
intelligence community
considers him to be an urban legend but
there are a few classified reports that
dick grayson had read that showed a kind
of run-in between the great tin
and china and ghost maker himself and so
it's one of these things that if you
knew where to look
you could find evidence that ghost maker
was real right but it's one of these
things where he would basically show up
into a city for about a year or so he
would eliminate
all the crime and then he would leave
before anybody ever really even knew he
was there or or without anybody ever
even knowing he was ever there
right so like he's just that wildly
capable you know and so this guy
is you know very much lives up to his
namesake he's a ghost
right this guy is a phantom now the
funny thing about this and as i was
reading this
this screams the winter soldier from ed
brubaker's captain america right
now it's not the first time we've ever
seen anything like that right ed
brubaker was not the very first person
to ever take a character who previously
died and then brought them back as
somebody who had been used for espionage
right
ed brubaker was not the first person to
ever do that right so before people show
up see this is dc
stealing from marvel and i guess i mean
if you consider ed brubaker to be the
only person who ever do that in the
history of literature
uh then sure i guess but that's not true
so uh so it kind of it reminded me of
that
in a lot of different ways right but the
cool thing about this is you end up
picking back up with barbara gordon
and you have cassandra kane who's
basically talking to her and saying hey
look you know we don't we're here at the
site that this happened but the only
evidence we have in terms of where they
went
is a plant on the wall that basically
spells arkham and that's how we know
where he took him
the poison ivy plant what's left of
poison ivy is basically just telling
them like go to arkham asylum right now
from there we switch back over to arkham
itself and you've got clown hunter
you've got batman
and batman of course already being awake
when harley quinn wakes up uh town
hunter is like hey like
okay what's going on here right and of
course once she starts talking to him
clown hunter gets pissed right it's on
you know don't talk to me but batman
basically says
this is all a test right this is a test
by ghost maker to prove
that you clown hunter are every bit as
bad as he believes you are that if you
give a criminal
the the means to commit a crime that's
what they will do because
criminals are bad people and criminals
commit crimes that they cannot be
redeemed they cannot be fixed they
cannot become
better people that they just don't
change ghost makers gregory house
from house md people don't change
but you know clown hunter kind of seems
to live up to this expectation that he
ends up discovering a couple of these
swords the clown i'm sorry that ghost
maker had left for him
and then when batman's like pleading
with him saying no like do not do this
if you do this
you will prove ghost maker right the
response to clown hunter is i don't
really care right she was there the
night the joker killed my parents and so
even if it proves the point of ghost
maker i don't
care i clown hunter am going to kill
harley quinn but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
you